thank you
very much
okay
let's do it can you hear me okay
all right uh hi everyone my name is Arun
I'm a fellow this uh semester at Simon's
and I'll be talking to you about some
cool work I've done on Sports Vacation
by a bunch of nice techniques
so what's the plan for the talk I'll
talk briefly about everything I tend to
work on the things I like to think about
in theorized in theory some background
on the problem
and then I'll talk about the results we
have in this talk and then hopefully
we'll have some questions although I
think people want to get to break
right uh there's two broad camps of like
what I tend to work on it's going to be
a mixture of convex optimization and
fast graph algorithms but instead of
thinking of them sort of instead of
thinking them as sort of disjoint sets I
think a more useful way of like
organizing my general research portfolio
is a spectrum I have on one side
Hardware convex optimizations like such
as like using higher order methods for
better structured convex optimization uh
semi-definite programming regression all
the way over to like laplacian solvers
and graph sketches which are very
traditional graph algorithms I could say
so it'll be talking about in this talk
is something in the middle uh it's going
to be something maybe everyone in the
audience can understand and might find
interesting and it's going to be new
approaches for sparsification
so if any of you went to the boot camp
um
you might see two Sean's version of
spartification which is like graphs
versification
and this talk we're going to be talking
about something a bit more General so we
have like sort of a meta problem we have
some well-behaved objects a 10203
and our goal is we want to find some
non-negative weights where most of them
are zero
such that the collection of re-weighted
objects satisfy some property of the
original it preserves something useful
so let's talk that's the version I said
in the previous slide is quite you know
General it recovers a bunch of things
Not Just Sports vacation so the version
I'm going to be talking about in this uh
next few slides is the following instead
of having objects and generally have
functions of 1x o2x Etc
so these for example could represent
Edge laplacians or hyper edges uh
quadratic forms or even arbitrary norms
and our goal is to find sparse weights
which preserve the sum of these objects
for all X
so if you think about this this sort of
resembles the version of sparsification
that works for graphs and in fact like
because oi is a very general object it's
an arbitrary function this notion
captures a lot more stuff than you could
get with just graph sourceification
so why is this problem interesting why
do we need this full generality it
actually captures a bunch of
interesting cases that are both useful
in algorithms and also like
theoretically nice so several of these
things are useful in algorithms like
graph sparsification Matrix turn off
versions of this are good for
approximate regression
and many open questions as to like when
this is possible like the TCS toolkit
the thing I learned in grad school don't
solve most of the things I'm going to be
talking about in this class you need to
introduce some new ideas
and hopefully you'll find the results
tool
all right so as a quick warm up I'll
talk very briefly about graph
sourceification again some graph
sporcification we have some dense
weighted graph and we want
a sparse related graph
such that the re-weighted sparse graph
is approximately the dense graph
so we can map this directly onto the
notion of sparsification described we
treat every Edge to blockchain as a
function by like interpreting it as its
quadratic form
and our goal is to find a re-weighting
of these Edge LaPlace and functions
which is a graph spectral sparsifier in
this sense
where of course that notation there
refers to like semi-definite ordering
which is exactly equivalent to the
notion I described earlier
right
so as we saw a couple weeks ago random
sampling works very easily to get uh
basically the right Bound for this you
can get n log n over Epsilon squared uh
size sparsification by just sampling
edges randomly
one question that might be interesting
is can you generalize this Beyond
matrices like this works for graphs it
works for matrices more broadly can you
make this work for anything else
so you might think that you could do
some turn off style arguments the main
issue with this is that this whole
approach requires linearity very
strongly
so you really need something new
so let me talk about the most General
result in this collection
so let's have some collection of N1 N2
and three being just some semi Norms so
semi Norms are convex functions which
have this linear scaling property
and our goal is to find some sparse
weights which approximate this sum
it was a very powerful primitive and it
immediately recovers a bunch of results
from the modern TCF Literature Like
graph cut specification hypergraph
conspircification and in fact you can
use this to sparsify some symmetrics and
bunch of their functions which is a
problem that's been studied quite a lot
by I think a completely different
community
so
a very slight modification is also get
you spectral Sports suppliers so this is
a very very general set of techniques
the main obstacle though like it's great
if we could get this the main issue is
that this is super duper non-linear like
you know with a matrix you can sort of
like imagine you know a matrix is being
some sort of linear operator on Space
arbitrary convex functions can do all
sorts of weird things so any sort of
analysis that you might want that uses
physical linearity just immediately
Falls fall short so we need something
completely new
so
if we actually developed this completely
new thing and we actually got this main
result which says that you can get
sparsifiers of near linear size
basically up to log factors the same as
you could get for graphs for Norms as
well and you can get exactly the same
notion
the algorithm is also very sort of
conceptually similar it's essentially
sampling by some probabilities and
re-weighting you essentially sample by
this weird probability to find this
expected value
and as a very like ones very brief ones
in summary of what we actually did uh we
just basically combined uh an approach
based on something called chaining some
clever tricks and surprisingly bounds in
the kls constant appear That's sort of
the appearance of the 3.5 and why it's
not three
that's our main result uh for this talk
but we actually have some other things
that we could have done so that the
results I said is sort of stated out of
order uh we started with this problem
called hyper gas fortification and then
sort of stumbled on Norm sourcifications
of results but hypercraft Sports
application is interesting in its own
right so here our functions are these
hyper Edge energy functions so it's like
the maximum squared pairwise difference
for any UV and belonging to a hyper Edge
and this directly generalizes
spectrograph's forcification like if
every hyper extra size two there's only
two choices for u and v and clearly uu
and VV both give zero
so this is like sort of an interesting
problem personally for me like it's been
studied in TCS for maybe 10 years now
but I personally find is an interesting
problem because it's sort of the easiest
hard case for the standard toolkit like
we have things that work for graph
sporcification both spectral and cut but
all of those sort of approaches don't
work for hyper graphs even though
they're very very closely structured
actual graphs
uh yes so that's sort of what I was
saying this result gets you hypergraph
sparsification in the full sense yes if
you take the square root of this that's
precisely a semi-norm
good point
yeah that's our main result for hypercut
sports vacation we actually managed to
prove a better bound than we could get
in general for hyper edges for
hypergraphs where every hyper Edge is
small size at most are
you can find these weights which have
this many non-zero entries which as you
might notice is like only a log r factor
away from what you could get for graphs
so for R constant this exactly recovers
the bound you get with Matrix turn off
up to some Universal constant
and very interestingly this algorithm
you could recover like a version of this
result via our sparsification of norms
paper but the algorithm to get you this
tighter your bound is completely
different like the sampling
probabilities are like essentially
leverage scores of some graph that are
like totally different
so I personally find it an interesting
question why you can do so much better
for this problem of hypergraphs with
such a different set of weights
and again like the proof's hand wave is
basically you just combine approach
based on generic chaining with an
analysis based on growth functionals
just a bunch of math
okay so now for something pretty
different uh I'll go back to matrices
for a second
so if you remember with Matrix turn off
from switch on stock you have a
sparsification with n log n over Epsilon
Square edges
great it turns out though that
surprisingly this is not tight you can
do better uh this is paper by Batson
spielmann and srivastava who's in the
audience which gets you this bound to
van over Epsilon squared so you can save
this log factor and this turns out to be
the right answer
so this is sort of an interesting
existential point but maybe there's a
question can you find these efficiently
and can you find sparsifiers of this
quality in some restricted settings like
let's say enforce you know all the
degrees of My Graph have to be preserved
what can I do
so the previous work for this problem
this has been studied finding this
linear size these linear size force of
fires and good time
and most previous work follows a very
basic template of just trying to find
some edges to add to a sparsifier a few
at a time so the original paper added
them one at a time some more uh some
work later found that you could add like
basically root n edges at a time it's
been pushed down
our setup is completely different from
this instead of like adding edges to a
sparsifier we basically decide to like
partition the graph we reduce an image
graph to like a 0.99 mmh graph sort of
reduction by constant Factor
and the idea is we sort of used for this
are strongly borrowed from this thing
called constructive discrepancy Theory
so what do we do like if you remember
the problem of constructing a sparsifier
we want LG and LH to be spectrally close
if we sort of re-weight every Edge in G
by this factor of one plus XE
personification is just equivalent to
this Matrix here being small
and so it suffices for our main goal of
finding some Vector X where most of the
entries or remote like only a constant
fraction of the entries are equal to
minus one like most of the entries can
be anything but if like maybe one
percent of the entries are small equal
to minus one then applying this to form
LH means that you've deleted one percent
of your ideas from your graph
and there's a theorem you can prove that
the set of small uh X it's like a small
incentive the spectral Norm being small
is large large is a technical term here
so given this we actually have a nice
result that says if I have a large set I
can find a point which belongs to K and
the hypercube where many entries are
equal to minus one so this is exactly
the goal I want the whole question now
is finding this
so the algorithm for this is just some
fairly complex conduct optimization
problem
and our main idea is that you can solve
this problem approximately and that
gives you something good enough
like it turns out the objective function
for this is strongly convex so if I just
solve this to some approximate error I
find I know there exists a point
minimizer which has many types units so
my approximate minimizer has many near
tight constraints and I can round this
quickly and this is essentially good
enough to make the argument work
with this we actually improve upon
previous work by a quadratic Factor we
get linear size force of fires in time M
over episodes of 3.5 previous results
were like M of reps on the 6.5
considerably worse I think you can push
this down even further
and also more interestingly to me you
can actually show that this whole
approach tolerates linear Subspace
constraints so in particular you get
this thing called linear size degrees
preserving sparsifiers sort of a
stepping stone along the line too
um directed Spar suppliers for directed
graphs in almost a near time
and like this is very nice because the
previous state of the art required some
polynomial time and didn't even get
anoreps in square size
so finally I'll conclude with some
future directions some things I find
interesting
like if you remember from earlier
there's this whole like thing where like
sampling hypergraphs
there's two completely different set of
Weights which work for this you have
this weights that are defined from like
the sampling sum of norms the sort of
expectation of something and then I
claim there's something completely
different that also works to get you a
better bound but it's based on like some
sort of re-weighted Leverage score
business
is there some sort of unified theory
that works for this
also can you get like linear size
partification outside of matrices like
we have all of these tools which lose
log factors can you get something beyond
that that works for things other than
graphs or matrices
uh finally you can use parsify
asymmetric objects like everything in
this paper everything this talk requires
like origin symmetry of all the things
and finally can you use this for more
algorithmic things like do you really
need
um like just to have this as an
existential thing can you use this as a
subroutine in something
let's hopefully faster that's all I have
thanks
so I don't know any questions
yeah I have one question so in the
fashion setting as far as the fires were
useful as preconditioners for fashion
systems like minimizing quadratic form
in a Subspace is there something
analogous here can you use these is
there some notion of preconditioning for
some optimization problem in some work
that's hopefully coming out very soon we
can actually use some some stuff related
to sparse of incomes of norms for
improving like algorithms for regression
oh okay so it is possible it just is not
like directly applying chemical forms
you need some tricks
is there any other
so you said that these two approaches
give different probability distribution
so and you can do even in the case of
graphs I guess you can do this iterative
like version of specification does that
distribution is that this is that
related up to constant factors to the
leverage score distribution so it turns
out that in graphs both distributions
are exactly the same they're both
exactly leverage Wars yeah like it turns
like whenever there's some sort of
non-linearity they sort of become quite
different like in hyper graphs you can
sort of get away with some related
leverage scores for more General things
or like the Norms has a bunch of like
faces if you appear as a polytope that
approach doesn't work but some
completely different approach does but
the weights are I think inherently
different
okay well thanks a lot
[Music]
we have a break now and we'll meet again
until